rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message be a creator of your
world over to you Joe Dispenza Newtonian
world is all about the predictable it's
all about predicting the future but the
quantum model of reality isn't is about
causing an effect the moment you start
feeling abundant and worthy you are
generating wealth the moment you're
empowered and feel it you're beginning
to step towards your success
the moment you start feeling whole your
healing begins and when you love
yourself and you love all of life you'll
create an equal and now you're causing
an effect and I think that's that
the difference between living as a
victim in your world saying I am this
way because of this person or that thing
or this experience they made me think
and feel this way when you switch that
around you become a creator of your
world and you start saying my thinking
and my feeling is changing an outcome in
my life and now that's a whole different
game and we start believing more that
we're creators of reality how do we then
go from that like mechanistically to
begin this visualization process of
something that's empowering it's me in a
different state it's my future self is
it meditation is it what does that look
like if you're not being defined by a
vision of the future then you're left
with the old memories of the past and
you will be predictable in your life and
if you wake up in the morning and you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future as you see the same people and
you go to the same places and you do the
exact same thing at the exact same time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality how your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every /
in everything every place of the
experience has a neurological network in
your brain every experience that you
have with every person produces an
emotion so some people will use their
boss to reaffirm their addiction to
judgment they'll use their enemy to
reaffirm their addiction to hatred to
use their friends that we affirm their
addiction to suffering so now they need
the outer world to feel something so to
change them is to be greater than your
environment to be greater than the
conditions in your world and the
environment is that seductive so then
why is meditation the tool well let's
sit down let's close our eyes let's
disconnect from your outer environment
so if you're seeing less things is less
stimulation going to your brain if
you're playing soft music where you have
earplugs in less sensory information
coming to your brain so you're
disconnecting from your environment if
you can sit your body down and tell it
to stay like an animal stay right here
I'm gonna feed you when we're done you
can get up and check your emails you can
do all your texts but right now you're
gonna sit there and obey me so then when
you do that properly in the you're not
eating anything or smelling anything or
tasting anything you're not up
experiencing and feeling anything you
would have to agree with me that you're
being defined by a thought right so when
the body wants to go back to its
emotional past and you become aware that
your attention is on that emotion and
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy you're siphoning
your energy out of the present moment
into the past and you become aware of
that and you settle your body back down
in the present moment because it's
saying well it's eight o'clock you
normally get upset because you're in
traffic around this time and here you
are sitting and we're used to feeling
anger and you're off schedule oh it's 11
o'clock and usually check your emails
and judge everybody well the body is
looking for that that predictable
chemical state every time you become
aware that you're doing that and your
body is craving those emotions and you
settle it back down into the present
moment you're telling the body it's no
longer the mind that you're the mind and
now your will is getting greater than
the program and if you keep doing this
over and over again over and all
again over and over again just like
training a stallion or a dog it's just
gonna say I'm gonna sit and the moment
that happens the body's no longer the
mind when it finally surrenders there's
a liberation of energy we go from
particle to wave from matter to energy
and we free ourselves from the chains of
those emotions that keep us in the in
the familiar past and we've seen this
thousands of times in fact we can
actually predict it now on a brain scan
I'm a big believer in the science of
meditation although I haven't figured
out how to make it work for me I've
tried books apps videos training
one-on-one sessions a lot of different
techniques but I haven't figured out how
to make it work for me yet that being
said I'm a big believer in Joe's message
I think if you stick in the same
environment that you are in you will
continue to repeat the same mistakes the
same habits the same routines and stay
where you are
the path that I chose to get out of it
is to force change my environment
through videos what I mean by that is
that I consume a lot of videos and
making this channel and every time I do
I learn something from different people
that is a shock to my system it shocks
my environment that forces me to change
in a think a different way because I'm
injecting new people constantly in my
life so Joe as an example I never heard
about Joe before we did the top ten was
a success on him I never heard of him
and that's my own ignorance and and
maybe you super successful super famous
there's a lot of super successful famous
people that I had never heard of and Joe
was one of them but by meeting him by
learning about him by digesting his
content it's a shock to my system it
forced changes my environment so the key
is to find the things that shocked your
system that forced changed your
environment and not just one video or
one book but a consistent source and so
if you're reading books as an example
it's a great way to learn from new
people don't just read one book because
you change while you're reading that
book but then you fall back to your old
habits once you finish that book you
need a constant source of new books are
gonna feed your brain just like watching
a video watching one video from Joe
Dispenza likely won't be enough
a constant source and so whether it's
watching my channel whether it's
watching Tom Beal use channel or Lewis
house whoever it is a daily and constant
injection that introduce you to new
people new ideas new ways of thinking
that force change your environment is
the path that I found to break free of
the historical habits and routines that
keep you where you are and ultimately
for me I would love for you to go off
and explore some of the people that I
have profiled if if Joe's message
resonates so deeply with you and that
means you spend the next six months
never watch another video from mine
again but diving deep into Joe's world
that makes me so pumped and happy I
don't care if you're watching every
single one of my video my goal is to
unlock your potential and if that means
you have to abandon me forever or for a
short amount of time I love it as long
as you are learning and growing so I've
got a really special bonus clip for you
to think you're gonna enjoy but before
that question of the day I want to know
what are you doing to shock your
environment to force change your
thinking let me know leave it down the
comments below
I realized I'd say two years ago but
especially in the last six months very
recent that and this is the part that
would make my Tim of five years ago just
Crane like vomit a little in his own
mouth
which is I'm not gonna mince words I
still have trouble sayings like
self-love is not an indulgence it's not
a nice to have it is a prerequisite even
if all you want to do is feel successful
and take care of the people you love the
most to really take care of them
you have to as I've heard said put on
your oxygen mask first and if you don't
do that like you you are also
shortchanging your ability to care for
other people completely and that that's
been a very very much an hundred and
eighty degree about-face for me right
because for a long time I was like I
don't need to care for myself mmm like
that's the word keeps going back to me
which is self-indulgent like this is
self-indulgent mink who cares raise your
standard Apple as a cool it's core value
is that
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's something serene if you want
to learn more from Joe check at the top
ten rules video I did on him the link is
right next to me continue to believe I
hope you enjoy today's shot at
vinspresso and I'll see you on the next
video so if it's possible that our
thoughts could make us sick is it
possible that our thoughts could make us
well